[Music]
merlin big deal now frank just told me
your merlin is slightly terrifying so
how would you describe him
i i'm not sure if he's terrifying well
he might have a sort of terrifying past
find out about you know halfway through
the series
yeah he's you know he's been through
some troubling times
and he's done certain things he's not
proud of uh
and when we first pick him up now he's a
drunkard
he's lost his magic he seems quite
cynical
uh and that's yeah that's where we can
first pick him up
um was that you know the main draw for
you coming onto this project or have you
always been a fan of the arthurian
legends
um not the arthurian legend per se but
i've always been a fan of the fantasy
genre
yeah reading the lord of the rings books
and and you know
robert jordan david eddings and all of
that stuff i loved that growing up
and when i was like my favorite film was
errol flynn's robin hood
so when all the kids took like you know
football classes i took
horseback riding and fencing instead
amazing so you're like already preparing
for this series for vikings as well you
know way long ago
yeah so would you say working on vikings
definitely helped prepare you for
shooting this series because i heard
there were some
interesting challenges when it came to
shooting on locations
for sure um you know i've done five
years of like
wet fields in ireland you know in
leather outfits
with an axe in my head actually this
shoot was a bit drier experience for me
because
i was more in castles and other i wasn't
you know as
you know as as exposed to the elements
as i have been before
yeah um
um it seems like your fans online are so
excited for you
to take on the role of merlin your
vikings co-stars have gone online and
they're giving their love and support
how excited are you for your fans to see
you in this role
um sorry i lost you there for a little
bit but i think i heard your question
i'm super excited to share it with with
all the fans
uh and i think like this this show is
such a generous show it's such a ride
um i watched it all in like one go or
two goes because i only first had access
to the first five episodes
so for me i think a great ride um and i
think you will know like if this is your
cup of tea you will know immediately and
you will love it
and if it isn't it isn't you know
because it's like it's a specific genre
uh but i'm a fan of the genre so i love
it i just when i watch it i just want to
know what happens next
and i can't wait to share my merlin with
the world either yeah
now catherine is such a force you know
in any project that she works on what
was it like working with her
it was amazing uh already from the
get-go
before i i got the role when i was
auditioning and did a chemistry read
with her
yeah you know that was amazing that's
when i was like okay
this is something i really want to do
because i knew that she was going to
carry this on on her shoulders and she's
such a talented actress
and such a sweet person yeah what was it
like for you
you know physically transforming into
this character as well because there's
some moments from the trailers i'm like
oh this is gonna be good
yeah um well it was like i don't know
it's always hard to
define that but and when we first pick
him up he's this sort of cellar dweller
in like a
big blue robe and that you know the
the costume gives you a lot of
physicality as well
and so that was one aspect and then as
the story progresses there are like
different
you know aspects to merlin that i had to
explore physically like when he's
injured when he has i don't want to
spoil the story but there's a lot of
physicality he's getting
hurt and he's getting so there's yeah
it's a very physical role
which is what i like yeah and you're
good at that
um so i'm kind of asking everybody in
the cast this question um if you had
your hands on a magical sword how would
you use it
i will would um i don't know
i think i would sort of establish some
sort of global democracy
where everyone got an equal vote into
who was
eligible enough to to carry that sort of
ultimate power
yeah that's a good answer i wouldn't
want to
heal it myself i'd give it to someone
suitable
you